unsere scholz kenner wissen wie der
kanzler tickt und wir sind jetzt mit
einem echten scholz kinder verbunden mit
lars haider vom hamburger abendblatt er
auch die scholz biografie der weg zur
macht geschrieben hat und diese woche
kommt auch sein neues buch heraus schön
dass sie bei uns sind hätten sie jemals
damit gerechnet dass olaf scholz
bundeskanzler wird
das klingt es doof aber ja ich habe
damit gerechnet
als er in hamburg anfing war man relativ
schnell dass ihm hamburg zu klein wird
zu eng wird und dass der eigentlich mehr
will und spätestens ab 20 17 ändere ich
nicht ein gespräch in den urlaub schulz
immer wieder davon sprach dass man ja
als spd die cdu csu und angela merkel
schlagen könnte und wenn urlaub holzmann
sagte da meinte er natürlich nicht
martin schulz sondern er meinte sich und
20 18 spätestens hatte dann wäre den
klaren plan sein plan war als
bundesfinanzminister und als vizekanzler
nach berlin zu gehen um dann dort am
ende der legislaturperiode von angela
merkel derjenige zu sein der ihr folgen
kann und seine idee war dass die
menschen ja die cdu csu in den
vergangenen jahren 48 jahren nicht
gewählt haben wegen der cdu csu sondern
weil sie angela merkel so gut finden und
er wollte sich als männlicher merkel
positionieren und das ist ihnen ja
extrem gut gelungen interessant in dem
zusammenhang ist übrigens dass die
cdu/csu das nicht gemerkt hat dass wie
wichtig angela merkel für die partei war
und dass sie dachte die menschen da
draußen die wählerinnen und wähler
wollen eine erneuerung das wollten sie
nicht sie wollten eigentlich dass es so
ähnlich weitergeht wie mit angela merkel
und deshalb oder scholz erkannt und ist
jetzt bundeskanzler
was macht mäßig qualifiziert ihn denn um
dann eben diesen langen weg an die macht
ins kanzleramt gegangen zu sein
naja was sind qualifiziert ist glaube
ich erstens dass er sowas wie eine
ausbildung zum bundeskanzler hinter sich
hat er war abgeordneter aber
generalsekretär arbeitsminister
hamburger bürgermeister war
finanzminister also viel besser kann man
sich auf dieses amt glaube ich kann ich
vorbereitet es hat lange gedauert er ist
jetzt 63 jahre alt aus er bringt die
erfahrung mit ich habe es noch nicht
genau zusammengerechnet aber
wahrscheinlich wird urlaub scholz
alleine mehr regierungserfahrung haben
als alle anderen ministerinnen und
minister die an land hat das ist der
eine punkt unter anderen punkt er hat
alle wichtigen politischen fragen die
kleinen und die großen mehrfach durch
doch er hat sich durch druck und er
kennt sich mit ihnen über politik
spricht erkennt sich quasi in den
meisten feldern so gut aus besser als
andere erkannt dass nicht so gut
verkaufen wie andere erkannt keine
tollen reden erhalten ist sehr spröde
für uns journalisten ist es oft eine
qual mit ihm zu sprechen weil er macht
alles aber er antwortet auf fragen aber
ich traue ich schon zu dass er das
worauf es jetzt ankommt wirklich kann
und am ende kommt es darauf an robin
alexander von der welt hat mal gesagt
das ist ja nicht verkehrt wenn ein
kanzler macht kompetenz gewählt wird und
ich glaube das trifft sowohl auf angela
merkel als auch ohne schultz trotzdem
nennen sie stolz auch ein besserwisser
in ihrem buch und auch sonst sagen sie
der ist schon auch type besserwisser
woran machen sie das fest na ja also das
ist ein besserwisser
früher war ein besserwisser hat wie man
ihn so kennt in ihrer negativen sinne
als juso da hat er den menschen auch
schon die welt erklärt es gibt ja
anekdoten das lg hat schröder als junger
mann als generalsekretär dann
unterbrochen hat also sinngemäß gesagt
hat wenn es um ein thema ging gehört
dass jetzt mal das andere die sich
besser auskennen die anderen waren er
und er weiß viele dinge halt einfach
besser als andere also de facto weise
sie besser und er glaubt sie auch besser
zu wissen das macht so ein gespräch mit
olaf scholz dann auch glaube ich nicht
einfach wenn man christian lindner am
robert habeck ist also so zweifeln und
olaf scholz das sind zwei dinge die
nicht zusammenpassen
in der ganzen recherche für ihr buch das
sie ja morgen vorstellen mit nicht
irgendjemandem sondern mit gerd schröder
der heute früh auch auf der tribüne saß
im bundestag mit seiner ehefrau da
finden sich nicht allzu viele private
einblicke das ist ja auch so schwierig
olaf scholz gibt es einfach nicht mehr
oder haben sie den eindruck dass er das
wirklich komplett abschirmt
frist entscheiden das ist ja die frage
die immer alle stellte ist der mensch
eigentlich privat da muss man davon
ausgehen oder scholz steht morgens um 67
auf dann geht er vielleicht mal joggen
zwei drei mal die woche oder geht ruder
dann fängt er an zu arbeiten bis 23 24
uhren ist er zu hause und dann liest er
vielleicht noch mal ein buch das sich
mit politischen mit gesellschaftlichen
themen beschäftigt und viel mehr ist da
gar nicht übrig seine frau arbeitet wie
er in der politik ist eine erfolgreiche
bildungspolitikerin das heißt sie werden
auch über politik sprechen die haben
keine kinder die haben keine tiere die
haben keine großen hobbys wir sagen den
menschen oder scholz gibt es vor allem
als politiker und da ist dann gar nicht
so viel es gibt lustige episode wenn man
mal was versucht aus dem rauszukitzeln
etwas privates und dann bleibt so was
übrig wie das vermahlen hund hatte der
wurzel dies aber wie gesagt viel ist da
nicht aus man über den privatmenschen
schwarz weiß was interessant ist und
darüber kann man viele lange reden ist
diese beziehung diese ehe zu britta
ernst das ist glaube ich das privateste
was man über urlaub scholz sagen kann
und von dem man auch relativ viel war
klar
denn sie gerne auch danach mal aus dem
nähkästchen über diese liebesbeziehungen
die schon seit den 80er jahren andauert
also eine wirkliche konstante im leben
von olaf scholz ist ja und das ist auch
wenn man urlaub scholz mal erleben wir
das immer immer immer immer über
emotionen und gefühle spricht dann muss
man mit ihm über frauen sprechen über
seine frau er sagt ja ganz oft
neuerdings auch dass britta scholz alles
für ihn ist dass er ein anderer mensch
wäre ohne britta schulz die beiden
führen eine besondere beziehung beide
für beide ist dieses thema
gleichberechtigung total wichtig wenn
olaf scholz über seine frau spricht dann
sagt ja nicht meine frau sondern britta
ernst und britta ernst über ihren mann
spricht dann sagt sie nicht olaf scholz
sondern mein mann und dass dieses thema
gleichberechtigung für sie so wichtig
ist liegt daran dass sie da eine
traumatische erfahrung gemacht haben
britta ernst ist wie olaf scholz eine
große politikerin und sie war 2011 in
hamburg einig gesetzt als
schulpolitikerin hier schulsenatorin zu
werden und sie wäre es auch geworden und
sie ist nur deshalb nicht geworden weil
der mann der 2011 in hamburg
bürgermeister wurde also die regierung
anführte hat ihrem mann war olaf scholz
und das ist so ein moment den die beiden
nicht vergessen haben wo sie sich
gebracht haben die kann es sein dass in
einem land wie deutschland im 21
jahrhundert frauen immer noch
zurückstehen müssen und auf ihren
partnerinnen sich nehmen müssen und
deshalb ist olaf scholz aufgrund dieser
erfahrung dieses thema
gleichberechtigung so wichtig deshalb
hatte halt bis zuletzt auch damit
gewartet das paar das die regierung zu
besetzen weil es alles ihnen unglaublich
wichtig ist dass fakten zu schaffen zu
sagen meine regierung besteht zur hälfte
aus frauen und zur hälfte aus männern er
ist tatsächlich olaf scholz für meine
begriffe der größte feminist unter
deutschlands politikern über 60
zumindest se halt keiner der bieter und
stoiber wahrsagen geburtstag seiner frau
denken würde dass sie ihm den rücken
frei gehalten hat und so eine
formulierung die findet gar nicht statt
und wenn man ihn darauf anspricht ob
denn seine frau jetzt auch
weiterarbeiten könnte wo er noch jetzt
kanzler ist dann kann man oder schott
wirklich
empört und wütend erleben danke lars
haider der analysiert hat den weg an die
macht von olaf scholz und sein neues
buch über den jetzt bundeskanzler morgen
hier im politischen berlin mit gerd
schröder auch offiziell vorstellen wird
danke dafür für das gespräch